[Music]
mom's movie bad mom's had plenty of
people laughing at the box office and
hey the producers laughed all the way to
the bank because the King made a hundred
and eighty three million dollars
worldwide and now the ladies are amping
up the cray-cray by bringing in more
moms for the sequel and we have your
first look feet here we go
I don't think I can do this sober you
guys want to get drunk at the food court
a little been so easy to do like bad
moms does Hawaii or bad mom says Vegas
and then you just replicate it this is
just the women a year later exactly
you're later so the timeline will be the
same and it's them doing Christmas
together
I spent months picking out the perfect
present for everyone you know the only
thing I get in return
coupons free back rub okay say Christmas
back it's great because we didn't want
to just do the same movie again so
rather than deal with the stresses of
school it deals the stresses of the
holidays but our mothers come in town
huh so it's this added layer of not only
are we overworked moms we're all so
bratty children at the same time Susan
Sarandon Cheryl Hines and Christine
Baranski joined the festive follow up as
naughty grand moms Cheryl Hines explain
your mama what was your reaction to that
so perfect I was I love Cheryl they're
like who do you want and I was like we
see risking my mom where's your tree I
didn't waste time Christmas tree
shopping I actually just wanted to enjoy
Christmas this year
Aimee you are a mom moms don't and joy
they give joy that's helping a mom works
is that wait a minute is that real or is
that just a bad mom's Christmas hits
theaters November 3rd
[Music]
you